but okay and why are you out saying so
right now don't use me on something you
just get what you listen to the program
yeah so how can I apologize for saying
what the Israeli prime minister said two
days before what I said no one's going
to people here have been offended and
isn't it time to say sorry if people
have been offended I am really sorry
about that
the no offense because I said the truth
exactly the same thing as the Prime
Minister of itself said 48 hours earlier
they've been offended by this group of
embittered old Blair RMP stirring up all
these accusations of anti-semitism where
as I said on the program eighty Labour
Party Jewish members are believing the
gardening today saying they've never
experienced anti-semitism we've had a
handful people who have said things were
anti-semitic they've been suspended or
expelled immediately by Jeremy and but
bigots don't join the Labor Party it's
filled with people
campaigning against racism anti-semitism
is that those that you've damaged Jeremy
Corbyn and the Labour Party I mean the
simple reality is that starting a few
weeks ago and the embittered old Blair
rmv started accusing the left candidate
the youth place on the NEC as being
anti-semitic now that's not true and
then this has taken off this being
whipped up we're streaking who's made
all these accusations against me asked
me to come and campaign for him when he
was selected to fight you see he
wouldn't have done that if he flies
anti-semitic so we're streaking the
scene this morning there were streaking
is saying this morning that he's are
campaigning for labour but having
elections you're in a radio studio
talking about Hitler surely you
recognize but there is not something
that the Labour Party wants me to wear
should ask why here in the day I was
ever invited Oh Blair eyes but wasted so
much of the party's time with all this
um these accusations of anti-semitism
which frankly aren't true the Labour
Party's always been opposed 20 semitism
high that's reality of it it's the I
mean I think we're streaking those in
bitter old Blair our MPs what they were
aiming to do was undermine our campaign
so that they could then launch a
Challenge the Jeremy's leadership after
the election why do you think Jeremy
Corbyn is not spoken to you I mean
Cody's a bit bizzy's and lecture non do
you know I think he's angry with you
I mean no I think he's very sad that all
this has happened the simple fact is did
you like to apologize at least a him
don't if I talk to Jeremy I do it to
jeremy not through the media I don't
trust the major as a venue for
communicating the truth but the simple
fact is this is my not I'm not doing any
more of this we just got to focus on
getting Sadiq Khan elected on Thursday
and in other parts of the country the
other labor candidates I'm no more
interviews after this who are these
bitter don't flare I think you talk or
the ones left I mean yeah I think you
might have felt John Mann wasn't
terribly happy when you're watching that
coverage you can take a stand down on
infants for the benefit of the Labour
Party in Jeremy Corbyn four years ago
when I lost the election if I said I'm
not standing for anything again I mean
the only thing I've been doing over the
last year is defending Jeremy from all
these ghastly old blaring how do you
regret the trouble that this is brought
Jeremy Corbyn under RT this is appalling
I mean complete disruption but it's not
caused by me saying the truth it's
caused by those MPs who I mean use one
thing after another and to undermine
Jeremy's leadership and I find labour
party members who generally are so angry
about the contact of these Labour MPs
their conduct I mean some of them say to
me I think they'd rather see the tour's
reelected than Jeremy in Downing Street
now that's the degree of bang these old
player rights are causing how much of
the will you will you apologize to
Jeremy now what I all I ever do is
answer question until the truth we how
much as important how much is this about
you enjoying the media circus do you
think I enjoy this
I mean well no you you took your hands
I'm talking about it well in that case
go away and don't answer some questions
I mean they might come out my house and
there's all of you there screaming
questions at me it's not my for you
you're a person who knows to stand for
the NEC again if it means that Jeremy
Corbyn move on and gets faster than I
thought
look hi 7 April event became nude I'll
do whatever it wants me to do I've said
exactly the same about Jeremy I think
this is what Jeremy I've heard your your
answer is very small picture sir and
yeah that's the end
how can I turn ready annoyed I'm going
to say sorry apart some another file